right we just learned this morning mgm  resorts bringing back  live shows according to its website mgm  will bring back seven acts starting  november  6th just a couple weeks away that  includes david copperfield the  jabberwockies  carrot top the thunder from down under  and others  the shows will have limited capacity of  course so in some cases they're going to  move them to larger theaters to increase  distancing in the audience but what  great news for everybody you guys and a  lot of people getting back to work  that's huge yeah we hinted at this a  little bit last week some of the shows i  think piffed the magic dragon and others  absinthe and now ball's starting to roll  a little bit good to see  great news